i i once and no hissing please was a
landlord in berkeley many years ago
and uh
okay that's sufficient uh
and uh
all everybody left one uh easter
vacation or thanksgiving vacation and so
i decided i would do this acid trip i'd
been planning and smoked dmt at the top
of the trip
and so i did
and i did and i had this very long
involved dmt trip in the elves and all
it was just totally out of control and
at the very height of this thing this
woman who i rented to upstairs who i
thought had gone home to minneapolis uh
came back and arrived by cab and came
pounding up the stairs with these two
suitcases let herself into the house and
ran around to my bedroom door and beat
on the door
and
you know you don't know me that well but
if i'm 500 miles up a jungle river
smoking a joint and a stiff crack 50
feet away the first thing i do is hide
the joint
i am a very paranoid person
so
being
you know on 500 mics of acid smoking dmt
and suddenly having this woman and i i
literally i i had like some kind of a
coronary and i i leaped off my bed and i
landed on my feet and
you know if you want you may try this
something about this enormous flash of
adrenaline added into the dmt
added in uh to this sudden
incredible physical exertion it was as
though i ripped the membrane
i ripped the membrane and i i was now
standing in my room but i had dragged
the trip through with me and the room
was full of elves ricocheting off the
floor and stealing and i had them they
were hanging off me like weasels
they were
and and they were sort of turning me
around in the room and and i and and
also simultaneously
uh one of these machines
had been dragged through into my bedroom
at the same time it was like about the
size
like this and it had all kinds it was
faceted and opalescent and glassy and
strange but
what was important about it was it had a
kind of a faceted top on it that was
clicking going
and every time it would click
it would launch a small plastic chit
across the room that had an alien letter
written on it
and these little plastic chips were
ricocheting off the wall and and piling
up and i was just standing apart
appalled looking at this situation and
then rosemary slams on the door again so
i stagger over to the door which was a
sliding wooden door and i just threw it
open and i looked at her and said
giddy miss toys
[Applause]
and she said
oh so you're doing that all right
and
and and backed up and then i just
slammed the door shut
and i pushed my way across the room and
i crawled under the bed
and i closed my eyes and i just said i'm
gonna stay here till i'm dead or it's
over
and i did
and i did
but it was
it was
uh
i mean what kind you know you're
supposed to learn something about your
psychology from an experience like that
it's ridiculous
[Music]
you